so you're one
of these uh aforementioned cognitive
systems
mortal but uh
thoughtful and you're connected to a
bunch like you said students
uh your wife your kids what do you
in your brief time here on earth this is
a meaning of life episode
so uh what do you hope this world will
remember you as what do you hope your
legacy will be
i don't think of legacy as much
as um maybe most people things
legacy oh it's kind of funny i'm i'm
consciously living the present
yes many students tell me you know oh
give us some career advice i'm like i'm
the wrong person
i've never made a career plan i still
have to make one
i um it's funny
to be both experiencing the past and the
present and the future but also
consciously living in the present
and just you know there's a conscious
decision we can make to not worry about
all that
which again goes back to the i'm the
lucky one kind of thing
[Laughter]
of living in the present and being happy
winning and being happy losing and um
there's a certain freedom that comes
with that but again a certain
um sort of i don't know ephemerity
uh of living for the present
but if you if you step back from all of
that where
basically my my current
modus operandis is live for the present
make you know every day the best you can
make
and just make the local
blip of local maxima of the universe of
the awesomeness
of the planet and the town and the
family that we live in
both academic family and you know
biological family
make it a little more awesome by being
generous to your friends being generous
to the people around you being
you know kind to your enemies and you
know
just showing level around you can't be
upset at people
if you truly love them if somebody yells
at you and
insults you every time you say the
slightest thing and yet when you see
them
you just see them with love it's a
beautiful feeling it's like
you know i'm feeling exactly like when i
look at my three-year-old who's like
screaming
even though i love her and i want her
good she's still screaming and saying
no no no no no and i'm like i love you i
genuinely
love you but i can i can sort of kind of
see that your brain is kind of stuck
in that little you know mode of anger
and you know there's plenty of people
out there who don't like me
and i see them with love as a child
that is stuck in a cognitive state
that they're eventually going to snap
out of or maybe not and that's okay
so there's that aspect of sort of you
know experiencing
you know life with the best intentions
and you know i love when i'm wrong
i i had a friend who was like one of the
smartest people i've ever met
who would basically say oh i love it
when i'm wrong because it makes me feel
human
[Laughter]
and it's so beautiful i mean she's
really one of the smartest people i've
ever met
and she was like it's such a good
feeling and
i love being wrong but there's
you know there's something about
self-improvement there's something about
sort of
how do i not make the most mistakes but
attempt the most rights and do the
fewest wrongs
but with the full knowledge that this
will happen that's one aspect
so so so through this life
in the present what's really funny is
and that's something that i've
experienced more and more really thanks
to you
and through this podcast is this
enormous number of people
who will basically comment wow i've been
following this guy for so many years now
or wow this guy has inspired so many of
us in computational biology
and so forth i'm like i don't know any
of that
but i'm only discovering this now
through these sort of
sharing our emotional states and our
cognitive state
with a wider audience where suddenly
i'm sort of realizing that wow maybe
i've had a legacy
yes like basically i've trained
generations of students
from mit and i've put all of my courses
freely online
since 2001 so basically all of my video
recordings of my lectures have been
online since 2001.
so countless generations of people from
across the world
will meet me at a conference and say
like i was at this conference where
somebody heard my voice it's like
i know this voice i've been listening to
your lectures yes and
it's just such a beautiful thing where
like we're sharing
widely and who knows which students will
get where
from whatever they catch out of these
lectures even if what they catch is just
inspiration
and passion and drive so
there's this intangible you know legacy
quote-unquote
that every one of us has through the
people we touch
one of my friends from undergrad
basically told me oh my mom remembers
you vividly from when she came to campus
i'm like i didn't even meet her
she's like no but she she sort of saw
you interacting with people and said wow
he's exuding this positive energy and
there's there's that aspect of sort of
just motivating people with your
kindness
with your passion with your generosity
and with your
you know just selflessness of of
you know just just just give doesn't
matter where it goes
i i've been to conferences where
basically people will you know i'll ask
them a question
and then they'll come back or like there
was a company where i asked somebody
question they said
oh in fact this entire project was
inspired by your question three years
ago at the same conference
yes i'm like wow and then on top of that
there's also the ripple effect so you're
speaking to the direct
influence of inspiration or education
but there's also like
the follow-on things that happened to
that and there's this ripple that
through
from you just this one individual and
from each
one of us from everyone that's what i
love about humanity
the fact that every one of us
shares genes and genetic variants
with very recent ancestors with everyone
else
so even if i die tomorrow my genes are
still
shared through my cousins and through my
uncles and through my
you know immediate family and of course
i'm lucky enough to have my own children
but even if you don't your genes are
still permeating through
all of the layers of your family so your
genes will have the legacy there yeah
oh every one of us yeah number two our
ideas are constantly intermingling with
each other
so there's no person living in the
planet
100 years from now who will not be
directly impacted by
everyone on the planet living here today
yeah through genetic inheritance
and through meme inheritance that's cool
to think that your ideas
manolas callous would touch
would uh touch every single person on
this planet
it's interesting but not just mine joe
smith who's looking at this right now
his ideas
will also touch everybody so there's
this interconnectedness of humanity
and and then i'm also a professor so my
day job
is legacy my day job is training not
just
the thousands of people who watch my
videos on the web but the people who are
actually in my class who basically come
to mit to
learn from a bunch of us
like the cognitive systems that were
shipped to this particular location and
who will then disperse back into all of
their home countries
yeah that's what makes america the
beacon of the world
we don't just export you know
goods we export people cognitive systems
we
we export people who are born here
and we also export training that people
born elsewhere will come here to get
and will then disseminate not just
whatever knowledge they got
but whatever ideals they learned and i
think that's something that's a legacy
of the u.s
that you cannot stop with political
isolation you cannot stop with economic
isolation
that's something that will continue to
happen through all the people we've
touched through our universities
so there's the students who took my
classes who are basically now going off
and teaching their classes
and i've trained generations of
computational biologists no one in
genomics who's gone through mit
hasn't taken my class so basically
there's this impact
through i mean there's so many people in
biotech who are like hey i took your
class that's what got me into the field
like
15 years ago it's just so beautiful yes
and then
there's the academic family that i have
so the students who are actually
studying with me who are my trainees
so this sort of mentorship of ancient
greece these
yeah so i basically have an academic
family
and we are a family there's this
such strong connection this bond of
you're part of the kelly's family so i
have a biological family
at home and i have an academic family on
campus and that academic family
has given me great grandchildren already
yes
so i've trained people who are now
professors at stanford cmu
harvard you know what you i mean
everywhere in the uh
on the world and these people have now
trained people
who are now having their own faculty
jobs
so there's basically people who see me
as their academic grandfather
and it's just so beautiful because you
don't have to wait for the 18 years of
cognitive
you know hardware development to to sort
of
have amazing conversation with people
these are fully grown humans fully grown
adult
who are you know cognitively super ready
and who are shaped by and i you know i
see some of these beautiful papers and
i'm like
i can see the touch of our lab in those
favors it's just so beautiful because
you're like
i've spent hours with these people
teaching them not just how to do a paper
but how to
think and this whole concept of
you know the first paper that we write
together is
an experience with every one of these
students so
you know i always tell them to write the
whole first draft and they know that i
will rewrite every word
but but the act of them writing it and
what i do is this like joint editing
sessions where i'm like let's co-edit
and with this co-editing we basically
have um
creative destruction so i share my zoom
screen
and i'm just thinking out loud as i'm
doing this and they're learning from
that process as opposed to like
come back two days later and they see a
bunch of red on a page i'm sort of
well that's not how you write this
that's not how you think about this
that's not
you know what's the point like this
morning i was having a i yes this
morning between six and eight am
i had a two-hour meeting going through
one of these papers
and then saying what's the point here
why why do you even show that it's just
a bunch of
points on a graph no what you have to do
is extract the meaning
do the homework for them and there's
this
nurturing this mentorship that sort of
creates now
a legacy which is infinite because
they've now gone off on the you know and
all of that is just humanity
then of course it's the papers i write
because yes
my day job is training students but it's
a research university
the way that they learn is through the
men's and manus
mind and hand it's the practical
training of actually doing research
and that research is a beneficial side
effect
of having these awesome papers that will
now
tell other people how to think there's
this paper we just
posted recently on med archive and one
of the most generous and
eloquent comments about it was like wow
this is a master class
in scientific writing in analysis
in biological interpretation and so
forth it's just so fulfilling from a
person i've never met or first say the
title of the paper brainstorm
i don't remember the title but it's
single cell dissection of schizophrenia
reveals it's so the two the two points
that we found
was this whole transcriptional
resilience like there's some individuals
who are schizophrenic but whose
they have an additional cell type or
initial sales state which we believe is
protective
and that cell state when they have it
will cause other cells to have normal
gene expression patterns
it's beautiful yeah and then that's that
cell
is connected with some of the pv
interneurons that are basically sending
these
inhibitory brain waves through the brain
and there basically there's a there's
another component of
there's a set of master regulators that
we discovered
who are controlling many of the genes
that are differentially expressed
and these master regulators are
themselves genetic targets
of schizophrenia and they are themselves
involved in both
synaptic connectivity and also in early
brain development
so there's this sort of
interconnectedness between synaptic
development axes and also this
transcription resilience so
i mean we basically made up a title that
combines all these concepts you have all
these concepts all these people working
together and
ultimately these minds condense it down
into a beautifully
exactly little document that lives on
and that document now has its own life
yeah our work has a hundred and a
hundred and twenty thousand citations
i mean that's not just people who read
it these are people who
used it to write something based on it
yeah i mean
that to me is it's just so
fulfilling to basically say wow i've
touched people
so i i don't think of my legacy as i
live every day
i just think of the beauty of the
present and the
power of interconnectedness and just i
feel like a kid in a candy shop
where i'm just like constantly you know
where do i what what package do i open
first
and um you know the lucky one
a jack of all trades a master of none
you